going to bring you some breaking news
now the US military says three of its
soldiers have been killed and 34 have
been injured in a drone attack on an
American base in Jordan there are around
2,900 American military personnel
stationed in Jordan as part of 20 two
deployed there to support Jordan's
operations against Isel we're going to
cross to Alan Fischer what more do we
know about what's been going on
Alan Joe Biden is on the campaign
trailes in South Carolina he's been
speaking in the last hour in a church in
South Carolina but he didn't mention
this he was briefed first thing on
Sunday morning about what happened on
Friday night in Jordan very close to
Northeast Syria uh they then issued a
paper statement from the White House and
Joe Biden says that he and his wife are
upset to hear the news of the death of
three servicemen that a number of other
servicemen had been injured he also adds
these service members embodied the very
best of our nation unwavering in their
bravery unflinching in their Duty
unbending in their commitment to our
country risking their own safety for the
safety of their fellow Americans and our
allies and partners with whom we stand
in the fight against terrorism it is a
fight we will not cease he described
them as Patriots in the highest sense
and he said they'll carry on the
commitment to fight terrorism and also
added we have no doubt we will hold all
those responsible to account at a time
and a manner of our choosing what is
interesting of course is that Joe Biden
says that he believes that a militant
group linked to Iran his words uh were
involved in this and just a few hours
ago The Joint Chiefs of Staff the head
of America's military in a television
interview was asked do you think that
Iran wants a war with America he
answered it very simply and said no but
we know since October the 7th there have
been a number of skirmishes between uh
the US and some of these groups
operating in those areas there there
have been a number of drone and missile
attacks on American forces but these are
the first casualties and that will
increase pressure on the White House a
white house which has been very keen to
try and keep a lid on the conflict in
Gaza and not see it expand to become a
much wider original conflict it will be
of course be a concern but as you say it
is coming at a time when we've seen the
US carrying out or being part of uh
operations against houthi rebels in
Yemen the houthis have been linked to
Iran and of course U Hamas the arm group
in Gaza has also been linked to Iran as
well and the US is supporting Israel in
its war on
Gaza look there's a pattern to these
things and we've seen it before in the
past it is of course a concern that this
has happened uh clearly the White House
will come under pressure to do something
about this to respond in some sort of
way but they don't want to see this
becoming a much wider War so the chances
of this escalating would would be slim I
think every analysts would give you that
idea but when Joe Biden says we will
respond in a time and a manner of our
choosing it's clear that there will be
some sort of operation and certainly
what we've seen over the last three
months is that when there has been
rocket and drone attacks and it was a
drone attack which killed these three
servicemen we have seen responses
normally within hours certainly within
24 it very rarely goes to 48 or 72 so
there will be a response from the United
States and perhaps the is a hope that
with this response that will keep a lid
on this because no one wants to see this
escalate into the Middle East not least
the Biden White House no one wants that
particularly in an election year we're
talking about Joe Biden being on the
campaign Trail just in the last few
hours and so there will be that sort of
response from the Americans that there
will be something almost for one of a
better word a Revenge attack and then
they are hoping that that will perhaps
draw a line under this incident although
it is clear that with what we've seen
with the pattern of rocket and drone
attacks this could well continue as long
as the United States is thought to be
given its tacit support to Israel and
what it's doing in the war in Gaza Alan
for now thank you very much indeed Alan
Fisher talking to us from Washington DC
we're going to bring in Al da senior
political analyst Maran Bashar Alam was
making the point there the us is going
to have to be pretty careful about how
it responds to this because it has to be
seen to do something in proportion to
what had the attack that has been
carried out um at the same time it
doesn't want to escalate a situation
which is already very
tense yes and I'm not sure this is a
balance that it can maintain it's going
to get more difficult I think the whole
notion that America wanted not to widen
the war in the Middle East that started
in Gaza I think it's going to notice uh
slowly but surely that it is widening
and that America is getting stuck and uh
whatever the mission is it's becoming
Mission
creep the fact that uh it has to attack
in Iraq and in Syria in Yemen and it has
to deploy throughout the Red Sea in the
East
Mediterranean America is getting sucked
in the shortest answer is the clearest
answer it's the simplest answer
President Biden needs to end the war in
Gaza this is no time to keep speaking
about Iran backed right if you read the
uh the Central Command that sencom U
Twitter feed right every tweet has Iran
backed right Iran backed this Iran
backed that Iran backed the other thing
but as the president himself admits that
while these groups might be Iran backed
but they're not necessarily Iran
directed that these attacks are not
necessarily part of a a back and forth
tit forat between Iran and the United
States through their proxies that there
are also groups from within likes for
example the likes of Hezbollah that's
acting not necessarily on orders from
Iran it's acting in solidarity with the
people in Palestine for example and
you're going to see something like that
in Syria and Iraq and in Yemen whereby
not everything is remote controlled from
tahan that things just happen and things
might get out of hand easily especially
with those asymmetrical enemies that the
United States has throughout the region
this will be you know quite dangerous
for a president uh who is an election
year and who vowed not to get sucked
into the Middle East warh because we've
seen in the past when there have been
attacks on say US military bases in Iraq
there has not always been an
instantaneous military response there is
one would imagine a period of
intelligence gathering to try to
establish who it was in the first place
that actually fired made made the attack
and then create some sort of as I say
proportional or directed uh response but
it is particularly interesting isn't it
that Joe Biden has chosen to specify
Iran within this rather than perhaps
wait and I'm not entirely sure when
these attacks have happened but rather
than wait a little bit longer just to
establish exactly who it was that fired
the that flew the Drone in no I think
the boogy man is is necessary you have
to have an an enemy more serious than uh
you know these little uh groups in
certain Borders or in certain gray areas
you see because it's a problem for the
United States if its enemies are in the
failed state of Yemen the failed state
of Syria and the failed and the failed
gray zones of Iraq right and part of
Lebanon as well right this is not
something you can afford to fight this
is how you get in trouble the United
States and probably our viewers around
the world don't remember that but the
United States had that experience 30
years ago in Somalia when it deployed to
Somalia and it thought it understood
things and it could
control and that probably everyone Rems
it from this famous or inFAMOUS block
Hawk Down or
something but these are not manageable
you think you can manage and you can
contain and you can find out who's
behind and who did this and you can
punish them like the United States tried
to do in Iraq by hitting alassad after
it was hit on al-assad base but in the
end of the day you're going to see
sooner or later that the United States
is going to be forced to redeploy out of
Syria redeploy out of Iraq and there's
already negotiations about that right
and it might start to redeploy out of
the Red Sea as well because none of this
you know has any end in sight what
exactly is the objective neutralizing
ing the Middle East if there is no
attempt at silencing tan itself and
apparently the president is not of the
mind that he wants to have a major war
with Iran that means these things are
just going to continue to happen today
three American soldiers are killed 24
are injured God knows how many of them
uh you know with heavy uh injuries but
this is going to continue and it's
already accumulating and it's already
expanding stick with us M because I want
to go to Russell s he's following
developments for us um from tan Russell
what are you hearing from there about
what's been
happening well as of now there has been
no reaction from the Iranian side yet
however um just to give a context here
Iran's position regarding such attacks
is is is quite clear they says that
these attacks are not conducted by Iran
and are not planned by Iran Iran is not
involved in these attacks that are being
carried carried out by the groups across
the region they say that they Iran has
allies um across the region however
these allies or so-called uh access of
the resistance makes their decision
based their on their own assessment so
that is Iran's position here and also it
says that the US is complicit in the
atrocities conducted by Israel and
access the the access of the resistance
is just reacting to israeli's uh
Israel's atrocities in Gaza so this is
Iran's official position as of now so
but since the beginning of the war in
Gaza we have seen that has been more
than 100 attacks on American bases in
Iraq in Syria and also in some other
places but in Yemen as the close to
Yemen as well we have seen that Iranian
allies have been involved in this but
this was the deadliest one for the first
time we're talking about the American
casualties and America is explicitly
accusing Iran of being behind this
attack so we have seen now there has
been a Tit for Tat policy between Iran
USA and America so far just to give it
chronology of this escalation so um Iran
uh Iran one of the top Iranian
revolutionary guard official razi musvi
has been attacked on December 25th by
Israel in Syria and has been killed and
then after that we have seen that Iran
as a response hit a Bas in air Bill
saying that it was a spy house conducted
or run by the Israeli secret service
mosad and then Iran has responded by
missiles to some groups in the north of
Syria and then at the same day we have
seen that Iran hit another base in
Pakistan and this was kind of the
reaction however right after that we
have seen on January 20th Israel has
conducted another attack and killed five
senior members of the Iranian
revolutionary guards which one of them
who Jah midar was the head of the the
the the the the special unit of he was
head of the intelligence unit of Al quz
and now Iran was saying that it's going
to respond in a time of its own choosing
so we do not know whether this attack is
a retaliation or not as of now there is
no reaction from the Iranian side but
now we know that the things are
escalating here and anytime as grow as
there are growing concerns that the war
could go beyond H Beyond Gaza and could
turn into a regional conflict but what
is clear here in Iran there is a growing
discontent among Iranians so Iranian
political Elites are feeling more and
more pressure from Iranians and Iranians
are saying that their country's response
to the Israeli attacks to the American
attacks is not adequate and will not
deter Americans or Israelis to attack on
the Iranian allies or even inside Iran
and that's why Iranian political Alle
here are feeling that pressure and
feeling urge to do something as of now
that is the context but as I said there
is not official statement yet from tan
Russ I want to ask you because we we
talk a lot about the response that is
made by uh the the government in tan we
also talk about the response that's made
by the Revolutionary guard in terms of
the Iranian people themselves is there
any sort of sense that you get about how
concerned they might be that this might
escalate that this might spill over from
Gaza from the West Bank and suddenly
become a essentially a face-to-face
conflict with Western powers
well here Iranians are quite clear they
do not want a original escalation they
do not want war to turn into a wider one
in the region because the USA knows the
Iranian officials know that a war direct
military confrontation with Israel means
not a war only with Israel but also with
the United States of America and that
could be a deadly want for Iran so Iran
so far that's why has avoided of having
a direct military confront confrontation
with Israel but rather it has been
encouraging its allies or the proxies or
what Iran calls the access of the
resistance to act so Iran's response has
been through its allies across the
region in Yemen by huis in the south of
Lebanon by hisbah and many of other
groups in Syria and in Iraq that is now
Iran's position however as I said there
is a growing discontent among Iranians
so Iran's position is quite difficult it
is on one hand it needs to satisfy the
the public pressure here but on the
other hand it knows that a regional
escalation particularly a direct war
with Israel and with with the United
States would have grave consequences so
that's is why for now Iranians are
trying to recalibrate their actions
their reactions to this this ongoing
crisis that's going on in Gaza and we
can see that there is a clear will from
Iran to see an end to the war on Gaza
Russell thank you very much indeed
that's Russell s bringing us up to date
from tan we're going to go back to Alan
fiser in Washington DC Allan I
understand you got some more uh
background to the briefing that Joe
Biden has been
receiving that's right we've been told
that Lloyd Austin who is the defense
secretary of course has been ill
recently and Jake Sullivan who's the
National Security adviser briefed the
president about what happened now what
is interesting is that the jordanians
are suggesting just in the last hour or
so that the attack didn't happen on
their side they're saying it was in the
Altan base which is in the northeast
corner of Syria uh that of course adds
to the complication of the situation
there because the United States really
has no mandate to be in Syria they moved
in during the fight against isil they
haven't gone away they are saying that
they're there to protect the oil fields
there they are not there at the
invitation of the Syrian government a
government which is recognized by by a
number of other governments around the
world we're also being told that 25 uh
servicemen all Army were injured in the
attack which also killed the three so
details will begin to become uh more and
more obvious in in the next few hours
but certainly it would appear from what
the jordanians are saying that the
United States believing that this
happened on Jordanian soil is being
rejected by the Jordanian government
itself and saying No this definitely
happened on Syrian soil we can go to
Colin Clark he's director of research at
the sufan group it's a global
intelligence in security consultancy
he's joining us from Pittsburgh thanks
very much indeed for being with us
what's your assessment of what's going
on at the
moment I think you know we we're still
waiting for for evidence but this is
very likely an attack by Iran back
militias uh operating in Iraq and Syria
uh we know the handful of groups that
are likely responsible or on the short
list of candidates this is the latest in
a tit fortat between the United States
excuse me and between these Iranian
backed groups uh and for any anybody
that's still doubtful uh this has really
proof positive that we're now in uh a
regional War there there's no denying
that US troops have been killed uh and
the United States will respond and will
respond forcefully whether that's in
Iran proper or against the proxies and
in the various countries where they
operate our correspondent in Iran was
making the point that has invariably
taken the stance that it is not in
charge of these groups or it certainly
doesn't direct them they may choose to
be linked with it but it does not direct
them is there a risk to the US if it
chooses to take action inside
Iran there's a huge risk of escalation
but let's be clear uh Iran can attempt
to distance itself as much as it wants
but we know that it funds trains and
equips these groups uh the irgc Cs force
is uh the the elite unit responsible for
training many of these groups and
increasing their skill level so uh you
know Tran can put out whatever
statements it wants um but there will be
a response forthcoming the question is
how do the United States calibrate it
without escalating the conflict further
uh but there has to be a response at
this point us blood has been shed I
think for the Biden Administration
there's going to be immense pressure to
respond in a way that shows the the
United States isn't going to sit back
and allow its troops to be attacked and
killed yeah it's going to be a fin line
though isn't it because again this is
the escalation of of a War or conflict
within the region is something that from
the get-go the US has said it absolutely
does not want it has to be as you were
saying seen to respond to some degree
but calibrating that response is going
to be very difficult not only because of
this incident but also of course because
of all the other smaller conflicts that
the US is finding itself involved in in
the
region absolutely and look the Biden
Administration is now being accused both
at home and abroad of being weak of
being feckless of not doing enough and
of not responding in force uh against
the houthis against uh other groups in
the region that have allowed it to
escalate to this point so I think uh
there's going to be a lot of pressure
we're likely to see uh action through
centcom or Central Command and the
question becomes you know what what
shape does this response take and how
does the United States thread the needle
uh to show the Iranians that it's not
going to sit back and allow its troops
to be killed uh so we're we're really on
the precipice here of some potentially
dangerous escalation we should be very
clear about that Colin Clark it's good
to get your thoughts on this and we
appreciate it thank you very much indeed
uh joining us on the line now is the
former Jordanian Deputy Prime Minister
jaad anani he's joining us from Aman
thank you very much indeed for being
with us so there is some confusion I
think about where this attack actually
took place there was a suggestion it had
happened in Syria and not in Jordan are
you able to clarify for us where your
understanding of this attack
is well according to the reports that
were issued by Western
media uh and so on I think it is inside
in the on the on the bord is very close
Bo to the north uh Western North Western
or Northeastern uh side of Jordan and
with this
borders uh with Syria and it is a very
small post so it is very close to the
Syrian border
but it is I think under the jurisdiction
of the American troops but still under
the sovereignty of Jordan what kind of
response would uh you expect Jordan to
make given the fact that this has
happened uh within its borders if what
you say is
true well I assume that Jordan would not
approve this because
uh it means that Jordan does not allow
anybody who is on its borders and within
its domain to be attacked inside Jordan
this would be turn war against Jordan
it's not only against Americans in this
case so in a way I think that we would
be we express our displeasure and anger
at such as a such event there's a
certain amount of speculation as you
might imagine at this stage about where
this drone originated from can you give
us an indication of what uh the
situation is inside Jordan with regards
to uh armed groups that are backed by
Iran for
example well you know right now
everybody in Jordan is completely
focused on what is happening in Gaza and
they don't see any other ugly happening
except that one yet this is because this
has happened inside Jordan there would
be a kind of a question mark on
everybody's mind in Jordan and query and
probably some people would really think
that we told you so about about Iran and
Iranian colonies so you have to be
careful uh but what is woring me a
little bit is that this war uh this uh
this uh these attacks on American troops
as your previous guest had just
indicated uh it's becoming an election
campaign issue in the United States
right now and so probably the people who
could probably benefit from such
an accident especially that nobody
actually had expected such an attack uh
on American troops in Jordan uh to have
come from people who really are
interested in seeing the war expanding
on to other fronts so we have to do our
own uh our own Bing and uh and and try
to find out exactly where this fire has
come from and who's the culprit behind
it and and call SP is Spade so what what
is the mood amongst jordanians at the
moment with regards to the risk of a
potential escalation How concerned are
people well they are you know because
they don't want this war to escalate
other
areas uh they see that uh only the only
people who are making statements about
expanding this war are the Israelis so
in a way we don't like it we don't like
Israeli position in Gaza and we have and
we also don't like to see the war
I should just explain to our viewers who
are looking at the map that we're
showing at the moment that the uh Mark
Tower 22 which is just on the border
between Jordan and Syria is where we
believe the US base uh is where this
drone attack uh has taken place and as
you can see it's very very close right
on the the the border between uh the two
countries um sah I want to ask you uh in
terms of the response that you would
expect Jordan to have diplomatically to
this um How concerned would Jordan be in
terms of retaining US troops on its soil
if it were to become the case that US
troops were to be increasing
targets well I I really don't think that
uh you know probably there would be some
voices who would say okay we don't want
any foreign any foreign presence inside
Jordan but these are few most Jordan Ian
don't mind that thing and I don't think
that it and I think this has come after
a long after long uh negotiations and
and it has been very wisely and very
carefully selected so that it is right
on the border as it just indicated and
so
therefore I believe that we are more
worried about the fact that the war
would
escalate with the presence of American
troops in Jordan or without it and
that's exactly what we don't want that
is the thing which is really
overhanging uh and keeping most
jordanians uh uh apprehensive and uh
waiting that's the former Jordanian
Deputy Prime Minister jaad anani talking
to us in sir thank you very much indeed
for your time